this NBA player might be going through
the longest trade request in league
history it's actually feran corkas of
the 76ers he requested a trade from the
Sixers back in 2018 because of playing
time the Sixers denied his request but
this would just be the beginning in 2019
he resigned with the team to a 2-year
deal and then another deal in 2021 but
things did not get better back in
February corkas requested another trade
and recently asked to be included in the
James Harden deal but Daryl Mory shut it
down again you may be wondering why does
corkas even want to trade well because
he was limited to 37 games last season
and only averaged 3.8 points and so far
this season He's only seen action in one
game so not only is he frustrated but
it's also not making him a very
attractive player to trade for with the
trade deadline being far away maybe this
season cork M will get his wish